well we've covered football and
grandkids our favorite golden girl did
not peg you for a Dorothy what have we
left out no maybe we've run out of stuff
to talk about
oh wait we forgot about your ex-husband
no one you're datin what do you wanna
know well I know not to piss him off
during a hailstorm he told you that he
wanted to throw himself under the bus
rather than let you push him
well did he tell you that I was naked
when he locked me out no why did he do
that cuz I was trying to hit him with a
golf club
naked with a golf club in a hails I know
it was the seventies remember what else
you got
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey John how we stood a so you dated
Hill and Dale you don't have the time do
you what are you doing here me what are
you doing here oh this is where I am
grave papers i chat with the other
patrons the people who like to bet on
football rub my head for luck John this
is June after juno wife of Jupiter and
queen of the gods
no after the fact that my mom got
knocked up in June so how do you two
know each other
what June here actually is Dale's
ex-wife I am commies ex-boyfriend is
that fun or weird yeah okay okay well
you went camping with Dale had that gun
oh I hesitate to speak ill of him I
divorced him say what you want it was
terrible
alright come on let's talk about
something else okay a lot of people here
like to talk about the game really you
speak sports now yeah I sure do what
check this out
hey Ref I suggest you go back to referee
school and this time pay attention in
class
you know doctor
he has his PhD in physics but his
specialty is quantum chromodynamics Wow
that sounds interesting
oh it is and I would tell you more about
it but I'm lucky I remembered the
quantum chromodynamics
and you didn't even have to rub his head
well it's here if the mood strikes